Tyree Nichols a young black man beaten
so badly by police he died from his
injuries the five Memphis officers who
were fired and faced criminal charges
for the beating all share something in
common with Nichols skin color and that
has not been lost on people here how do
you feel the fact that all five officers
were black do you have any thoughts on
that or not I have a lot of thoughts on
that um because it's for it to be our
own and I'm going to speak on my behalf
of my community for it to be our own
black brother brothers out there doing
that to another black brother that
actually destroys her heart because we
preach every day that black lives matter
and you know the white man is the
problem behind this and that but for it
to be our own people doing this to
another black brother it's more
devastating than ever historically in
the United States the job of being a
police officer was reserved for white
men but the last 10 to 15 years or so
there's been a push to change that the
thinking goes like this hiring more
black police officers primarily in
cities with large black populations
would help diversify the force and bring
down cases of police brutality Memphis
perhaps proving that theory was all
wrong
if Memphis is about 65 percent black and
about half the police force are
African-American officers one important
lesson to draw from this is to not be
naive and to believe that if we simply
put black people in the positions of
power but we don't change anything else
that things are going to get better
um that will not work well
some analysts say the issue is not skin
color but systematic problems with
policing that go beyond Memphis the
problem is the sort of Thin Blue Line
culture in general right this idea that
the police believe that they stand
between uh order and disorder and they
are you know sort of operating in U.S
society to protect order uh but really
what that has meant is they're operating
to protect those who have wealth they
operate to protect private property and
they operate to police to folks whom
they might see as threats to that
as for the family of Tyree Nichols they
just want Justice regardless of the skin
color of those accused Gabriel ozando Al
Jazeera Memphis